hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump says he believes a
coronavirus vaccine could be ready
in a matter of weeks are experts really
that close to unveiling a treatment
and if so will americans trust its
effectiveness
dr ashish jah dean of brown university's
school of public health
shares his insight and explains why he
feels we should let
science drive the timeline instead of
political figures
and republicans currently run the senate
but the party will need to defend
23 seats this election cycle compared to
senate democrats who are up for
re-election tom bevin the co-founder and
president of real clear politics
discusses the most contested races and
how much of a role he thinks president
trump's popularity
will play when it comes to the control
of congress
plus commentary by fox news
correspondent at large geraldo rivera
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you
you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon bream i'm
steve ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday september 16 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
the president says he is pushing for a
vaccine but not for political reasons
but how many of us are comfortable
taking a vaccine and what would it take
to make us ready and willing you know
the american people are paying for these
vaccines through
their tax dollars the data should be
accessible to the american people
i'm lisa brady the white house isn't the
only thing at stake in the 2020 race
republicans are also fighting to keep
control of the senate
somebody's going to have a good night on
november 3rd and if it's joe biden and
the democrats then he's going to
the democrats will win all these close
races or a lot of these close races the
majority of them
in in these toss-up senate races and i'm
geraldo rivera
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
multiple pharmaceutical companies are
working on a coveted vaccine and while
we've heard about setbacks many are
confident we will have one by the end of
the year
dr anthony faucis predicted a safe and
effective vaccine by the end of the year
the ceo of pfizer said this week a
vaccine could be distributed by then
president trump told fox and friends
this week he is pushing for a vaccine
but not for political reasons saying
we will have a vaccine in a matter of
weeks but
we're going to have it we're getting
very good results and it's really
looking good and they're great companies
pfizer johnson and johnson
moderna we have a lot of great companies
it's not just one
and they're all doing really well it's
going to be soon now will it be before
the election it could be in terms of we
have something
and we'll start delivering it
immediately upon getting it
but we're very close to getting the
vaccine and that's something i look
forward to
but are we looking forward to it some
polling shows we
are a bit skeptical a kaiser family
foundation poll earlier this
month found even if a vaccine is
available before election day
54 of us would not take it 62 percent
said they were concerned the fda might
approve a vaccine
before it's proven safe and effective
another poll taken between september 9th
and 11th from yahoo and yougov
found just 32 percent of u.s adults said
yes
when asked if they would get a covet
vaccine if and when it's available
more than half said they wanted to wait
and see how it affected
other folks who took it first a number
of pharmaceutical companies working on a
vaccine announced last week they'd
signed a pledge
promising that any coveted vaccine they
produced will be developed and tested
with high ethical standards and
sound scientific principles so i do
think we're going to have a vaccine
reasonably soon
dr ashish jah is the dean of the school
of public health at brown university
i think in the next couple of months
next few months
and the reason we have been able to
build a vaccine so
fast is because we've actually done a
lot of work
on a vaccine for the previous sars virus
and the scientific community has worked
incredibly hard on moving this forward
so
that's the reason we've been able to go
so fast um and i do think we'll have one
in the next couple of months
oh that's interesting where were we
doing that work in the united states or
where
globally was work a lot of it was done
in the uk
uh the you know the oxford astrozenica
vaccine
the oxford group had actually come
pretty far along on building a vaccine
for the previous sars virus
and so they were able to make some
moderate changes and that's
part of the reason uh they were able to
move so fast but we also had learned a
lot about
the previous stars virus so that's why
um
moderna and other companies were also
able to move fast
when president trump says that he sped
up the process with the fda
and as we know we have operation warp
speed how does one
quicken this kind of process and still
keep it
safe at the same time like is there a
balancing act
there or is it what you just said the
reason it can be sped up
is because of pre-existing research and
only pre-existing research
i think the pre-existing research has
helped a lot here i think that's a major
reason why we have been able to move so
fast
i think operation warp speed has been
great
it's not really been a major factor in
speeding up research
operation warp speed has been the main
focus of it has been about making sure
that we're making
millions of doses of the vaccine even
before we know whether it works or not
so that if it turns out to work we'll be
able to
have vaccines ready to go that's the
major
uh focus of operation warp speed the the
speed of this is not
really the fda it's really the
scientific community
and nih coming together
um the moderna vaccine for instance is
really funded and supported by nih
and nih scientists working with moderna
of the company
so i don't think the fda's had much to
do with it yeah they've been helpful
they could have slowed things down they
didn't but they are not the main reason
why we've been able to move so fast
doctors with the national institutes of
health have come out to say they're
concerned about the astrazeneca trial in
particular
i guess an unnamed patient had severe
inflammation of the spinal cord and it
is no longer hospitalized but
the i guess the injury was big enough
that they stopped the trial briefly
right
yep yeah so we did see last week a
pausing of the astrazeneca
oxford astrazeneca trial because of
spinal inflammation we
think that's what it was and now they
have restarted it in the uk but as of at
least today they have not restarted
the united states my biggest point on
all of this
is we need a lot more transparency and
openness about what happened
i mean i don't need to know the
patient's name but i need to know we all
need to know what happened what were the
details
um why was it paused what was the
decision to restart it
only that kind of openness and
transparency i think will
help people feel confident about the
vaccine
right now the companies have not been
forthcoming with that kind of
information and i i think
it's really um i think it's going to
make it harder for people to trust the
vaccine if we don't have that
transparency
yeah i mean speaking of that are you
worried by polling that shows many
americans are in fact
pretty skeptical of a vaccine especially
one that seems you know rushed i mean
of course a lot of us want one in theory
but it almost seems like if one's
available too soon it could
like it could backfire because no one
really wants to be among the first
outside of the
outside of the trials to to take it it
sounds like
yeah so this is why we've got to do this
carefully we have a long track record
of building safe and effective vaccines
and this is why i have been arguing that
as much as i desperately want a vaccine
and i'm enthusiastic and actually pretty
optimistic we're going to have one soon
we've got to let the science drive the
timeline so it is not helpful
when politicians are saying things like
oh we'll have one by election
day i'm like why election day i mean i
understand why election day but like
it's not the scientific timeline the
science doesn't care about election day
we've got to do it right and we've got
to do it safely
and my feeling is you know if that's
ready but if a safe effective vaccine is
ready by election day great if it's
december fine we just got to do it right
and i don't like it when politicians or
even company ceos
uh start predicting exactly which date
the vaccine will be ready
the science doesn't work that way like
you know science works at its own pace
even if you're going really fast no one
can perfectly predict when the vaccine
will be safe and effective and i wish we
would just let the process play out
well and speaking of politics you know
the democratic vice presidential nominee
kamala harris
said this month she would not take a
vaccine on the president's word
alone but more significantly she said
she believes that the scientists will
not get the last word
on a vaccine that they will be quote
muzzled or sidelined
however you feel about this president is
that even possible i mean we have a
whole process in place to approve and
market
medicines and vaccines in this country
right
we do and you know we have a long
tradition bipartisan tradition
of fda cdc being nonpartisan
organizations that like
we let them do their job without the
scientists do their job and fda
scientists are some of the best
scientists in the world and so
um the issue is i think what happened
with convalescent plasma
really shook the medical community
watching steve khan
stand up and say the things that he did
when we know that that's not what the
data showed
i think really made people very very
worried so i've been talking to a lot of
physician friends
uh you know people who are not political
who basically are saying
can i still trust the fda i also don't
think it's helpful when
you know when politicians on either side
of political law starts saying
i'm not going to take the vaccine i
don't think that's useful
either what i have said is that i'm very
personally when i think about you know
what would it take for me to
vaccinate my children vaccinate my
elderly parents
it's going to be the science and data
not what some politician
either says it's great or says it's
terrible i don't care i'm going to look
at the evidence and science and data
and let that drive my decision-making
we've got to make sure
the fda is not politically influenced by
this
i think both sides of the political
aisle have to back off and let the
science work
flesh that out briefly for me you're
you're talking to physicians and doctors
who were
who were who were talking about if they
could even if they could even trust the
fda
after the convalescent plasma
announcement i i thought convalescent
plasma was kosher but
what did dr han say that caught
everybody off guard
oh i think the convalescent plasma thing
was a was an utter disaster for the fda
possibly the
lowest moment in the in in fda
in modern fda history here's the basic
bottom line
we didn't have a high quality study that
showed that
that caused causing fundamentalism
plasma works and then dr han stood up
and said
uh things are just plain wrong like if
you give it to 100 people 35 survive
and that this is a major advancement
it's not and those of us who actually
practice medicine
uh i think could look at that and look
at the data and say
what are you talking about and that was
the reaction across
much of the medical community um and
and really because the fda has always
been such a gold standard they always
are the careful ones the
thoughtful ones the well-balanced um i
think steve han did himself
and the agency enormous harm um
and i what is at this point completely
clear is
he can't be the the decision maker on
the next one we've got to let the
leading scientists in the agency
uh who really have been to our career
people have to also speak up
because that's point about a vaccine
about a vaccine because it's going to be
very important
after the convalescent plasma press
conference dr han walked back his
comments calling criticisms of his
remarks justified
that what he should have said better is
that the data show a relative risk
reduction not an
absolute risk reduction but when we
asked the fda for any further comment
regarding jobs remarks
they pointed us to an op-ed written by
career fda executives
in which they write the foundational and
fundamental principles of the fda
remain steadfast to protect and promote
the health and well-being of the
american public
and they say based decisions in support
of their public health mission on sound
science
they also pointed us though to a duke
university-hosted webinar on covet
vaccine
approval logistics han defended the
plasma decision again
last week in an interview in dc saying
the totality of the evidence
was in support of the authorization and
again these
these scientists were there you know
many of them they've been there for
10 15 20 years they you know they came
in under a bush administration or an
obama administration they're
they're largely nonpartisan and they've
been making very good decisions uh
over the last few years including during
this pandemic
the convalescent plasma thing was a huge
breach of faith
and uh and you know but wait but wait
can we still use convalescent plasma
despite the announcement is convalescent
plasma still
somewhat helpful in in our i guess we
don't know vast we don't array of
antivirals or whatever
any treatments we have so there are
three randomized trials of convalescent
plasma none of them have shown any
benefit
and one of them actually showed more
harm but one of them showed maybe a bit
more ben but like but none of them hits
the physical significance
the bottom line is we don't know if
condolent plasma is useful
as a physician i don't know whom to give
it to i don't know whether i should give
it early or late
the bottom line is that's why nih
dr francis collins actually was pushing
against this eua
saying let's do a good quality clinical
trial
figure out if this thing actually works
and then decide
so yes you can use it you have no idea
if it's helpful or harmful
and it's people what is harmful is when
the fda chief
stands up and says you know it's going
to save all these lives
when everybody in the medical community
looks at him and says we know that's not
true that's not what the data says
um really distressing um so you would
then
as you said you would wait to hear from
somebody else we need to hear from the
scientists the top scientists at the fda
and there are a bunch of and they're
great um so
we need to hear from them and but more
than that we just need to see the data
like the data should be made publicly
available my take is
you know the american people are paying
for these vaccines through their tax
dollars
the data should be accessible to the
american people
dr ashish thank you so much for your
time all right see you well bye-bye
[Music]
this is geraldo rivera with your fox
news commentary
coming up the presidential race gets
most of the attention but there's also a
battle underway
for control of the u.s senate well i
think the american people should know
what it means
if the senate shifts control majority
leader mitch mcconnell says if democrats
win control the structure of the senate
would change under their priorities
including statehood for d.c and puerto
rico and ending the filibuster rule
which allows the minority party to block
legislation
what they're saying is they don't want
to win the argument
they want to change the rules in order
to guarantee
the outcome and i think the american
people need to be aware of that before
they vote
after democrats took back control of the
house in the 2018
midterms mcconnell started calling
himself the grim reaper
vowing to kill any socialist agenda now
democrats are urging voters to help
rescue
dozens of house passed bills buried in
the senate's legislative graveyard
minority leader chuck schumer frequently
railing against not only mcconnell's
leadership
but also the president this man has no
knowledge
about anything in several tight senate
races especially
a lot is riding on what happens at the
top of the ticket
there's not a lot of split ticket voting
that goes on anymore
tom bevin is co-founder and president of
real clear politics
if you look at the polling data you will
find particularly on the republican side
that a lot of these senate candidates
are tied very tightly to trump when his
numbers go up a couple of points in the
state
their numbers go up a couple of points
when his numbers go down their numbers
go down and so
um i think it's you know for better or
worse uh i think all these candidates
particularly the republican candidates
since donald trump is the incumbent
running for re-election
uh their fate is going to really be tied
to whether he's able to
win these you know states that are these
battleground states that that are going
to be
uh you know probably pretty close and if
he's able to do that
they will probably end up uh you know
he'll end up dragging them across the
finish line as well there's a wall
street journal report that in most
tv ads at least for house and senate
candidates they're not
mentioning the president on either side
so republicans
tending to steer clear if those ads
could reach voters in swing states
and then democrats sticking with policy
arguments which
isn't really what joe biden has been
doing he's been attacking
the president right
and i think that is a real tell for for
both
sides right uh in a state like
maine or colorado where you have
republican incumbents that are in
blue bluish states and you know they
don't want to talk about donald trump
as much as they want to sort of keep the
race localized
and democrats a lot of them are running
around you know
issues like healthcare which is what
democrats had such success on
uh in in 2018 at the house level
but uh i do think look there's a certain
part of the democratic base that is
motivated by
and we've seen this in the polling data
right negative partisanship they're not
super excited to turn out and vote for
joe biden
but they are motivated to turn out and
vote against donald trump and so you get
these democratic senate candidates that
are trying to
harness that um but but they they also
i think recognize that they have that's
not going to be enough for them they're
going to have to
also run on some real policy
forward-looking policy prescriptions and
visions that will
bring in the independent voters and
swing voters i have
in front of me the real clear politics
map which i encourage everyone to look
at
on the battle for the senate and you've
got six
senate races listed as toss-ups you
mentioned one of them already
in maine where the republican incumbent
is susan collins
known for sometimes splitting with the
president but also
known for backing him up sometimes on
some key issues like the brett kavanaugh
nomination to the u.s supreme court
springs to mind
you've also got michigan there's a race
there but that's one of the battleground
states in the presidential race too
north carolina
also a battleground in the presidential
race then you've got montana
a race in georgia and then iowa and i'm
wondering
if that one for example is a surprise to
you
with senator joni ernst maybe not a
shoe-in
in a state where the president did so
well four years ago
part of the problem is that we don't
have a lot of polling data
in some of these races uh particularly
while a state like florida
north carolina getting uh uh pulled a
ton at the presidential level so we have
a lot of senate polls there as well
i was not a place that that is really
getting polled at all so
if you look at our polling data there
you've only got the last poll which
showed joni ernst
up one point over uh her challenger
um theresa greenfield was taken
the last two days of july in the first
three days of august so we've gone
basically
uh you know six weeks or so without a
single pole in iowa so
um but the polling data does show that
race tight and i think that is
for a state that that trump won uh
you know joni ernst won in 2014 by eight
and a half points donald trump won iowa
by the
nine points or so um in 2016
it is surprising to see her struggling
as much as she is
some of the other races that you
mentioned um
it's it's much easier to see why someone
like cory gardner susan collins tom
tillis
are in the kind of races that they're in
so when you look at something like
you know a surprisingly close race maybe
in a state like iowa and then you look
at
nationally the map for these senate
battles
and really only a handful of toss-up
states and republicans having to defend
a lot more states than democrats this
time around
that overall a very discouraging picture
for republicans trying to hold on to the
senate or
is it closer than that so it's 53-47
right so democrats need to win
three seats and the white house right
which would get them to 50 50 and make
kamal harris as vice president the
tiebreaker or
if they don't win the white house they
would need to have a net gain of four
seats and the problem
for them is uh alabama where doug
jones is sort of the you know accidental
senator
running for re-election uh in a deeply
deeply red state
uh tommy tuberville is the republican
there
and is by all accounts uh you know
running well ahead there and so they
have to so that's a that's a net loss
for the democrats so they have to make
that up now if you if you go to
we have a feature on our site called the
no toss-up function senate no toss-up
and if you click on that
it'll allocate all the states based on
where the polls are right now and given
the fact that as i mentioned
iowa uh the democrat is leading there by
three tenths of what percentage point
that
race goes to the democrats um but they
would end up right now if the election
were held today and the polls
were exactly where our averages say they
are
the democrats would end up with a net
gain of four seats would take control of
the senate
so i do think it's it's it's not out of
the question that that the democrats uh
are able to clear that hurdle and take
control of senate but it's certainly
uh not out of the question that
republicans are able to maintain
it's it's all going to depend on on who
wins at the top of the ticket in my
opinion
we've seen this over and over somebody's
going to have a good night on november
3rd and if it's joe biden and the
democrats then he's going to
the democrats will win all these close
races uh or a lot of these close races
the majority of them
in in these toss-up senate races vice
versa if donald trump has a good night
you can bet that joni ernst and tom
tillis um
and you know the folks in georgia
david perdue and kelly loffler all those
folks are going to win
because donald trump's going to win the
states
in a nutshell what would you say or
would you say that there are
make or break races for
control of the senate you know if x y
and z doesn't happen in these states
then
forget it all is lost yeah
certainly you know we have we have
colorado and arizona
all already leaning democratic as those
are basically states that are
are poised to vote um and be pickups
for the democrats and so you look at a
place
like um north carolina is going to be a
crucial crucial race that
that state is is
one that trump won in 2016. not by a lot
and
um the polls have been closing they're
the last couple polls that we've
seen just come out this week um show the
center there
down to like a one point race i mean at
one point cal cunningham the challenger
democratic challenger had was up nine
points
on tom tillis his lead on average is
down to about 3.3 so
that's the race to me if if democrats
can win that race
they're going to win probably north
carolina and that's going to also put a
real damper on really restrict president
trump's
path to 270 electoral votes so i think
north carolina is sort of the focal
point for me you know susan collins up
in maine is another one i mean i
i see her as sort of the the claire
mccaskill of the
republican party right claire mccaskill
is the senator from missouri republicans
every cycle thought you know we got her
this time we got her this time and she
always managed to escape
she had like nine lives until they
finally
you know she was she ran up against it
and and this may be the year that it
that year for susan collins but
i wouldn't underestimate her ability to
as an incumbent to
you know find a way to to win she's she
has a history of doing that
um but again she needs trump to perform
better in that state to be able to pull
out that race
one last question and that is
are these races um just as much in
danger of the presidential race
possibly of not having a final result
on election night um depending on how
much mail-in voting expands
absolutely i mean again i'll go back to
north carolina
you know that race could be decided by a
handful of votes i mean it could be
and so in all these um in all these
states that are doing mail-in balloting
and all these you know county clerks
that are some of them
can't even start counting the ballots
until the polls close on election day
we're absolutely going to see at the
house level at the senate level at the
presidential level
this this counting that'll go on
two days three days a week after now
you know again if if the democrats have
a great night and they sweep all these
states
uh we we might know everything on
election night but if it is close and i
suspect it's going to be close given on
where things are headed
then yeah we could be not knowing who
has control of the senate for
uh you know for days or weeks
and it will be the same same in in terms
of knowing who's going to
end up being president well we're in the
home stretch
i guess you could say one one way or the
other at this point
a tom bevin president of real clear
politics
thank you so much for your time you
[Music]
[Applause]
better
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with bret bear with updates
from reporters on the trail and
in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race go to
foxnewspodcast.com and download the
campaign with brett bear now
it's time for your fox news commentary
geraldo
rivera what's on your mind joe biden is
apparently in trouble among latino
voters in florida
a new marist bill shows him running neck
to neck with president trump
in the sunshine state by comparison
hillary clinton
led trump in the very same poll by a
margin of 59
to 36 percent she ultimately lost the
state by a single point to donald trump
who incidentally is also now a resident
of florida
at 17 latinos are the nation's largest
minority group
blacks by comparison represent about 13
many latinos
are hard-working family oriented
socially conservative
and religious many are ripe for the
appeal of donald trump
they we crave respect and consideration
for vulnerable groups like the dreamers
good people brought here as kids through
no fault of their own
without documentation their status
remains in jeopardy although the
president has told me on the record
that quote nothing bad is going to
happen to them
joe biden's slipping support in florida
among latino voters is a function of
their feeling
overlooked taken for granted by the
so-called
social justice movement issues like
immigration
language the latino economy dreamers
and deportation are scarcely mentioned
by democratic politicians
the black lives matter of violence is
also a turn off to many but what latinos
i speak with most are
concerned about is that being taken for
granted
why for instance some wonder is the word
black now capitalized
while the word brown used to describe
the equally diverse latino population
is not capitalized unless and until
democrats
understand that the color of america is
changing at 55 million and counting
latinos who trace their origins from
places like
mexico central america venezuela
nicaragua
the dominican republic and puerto rico
want folks to notice
there's a new flavor in town it's salsa
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes